i will respond to more emails
than arthur smith will respond to
questions
when it comes to star receiver julio
jones arthur smith fending them off like
a superhero yesterday like he's finally
discovered his power and that's not
answering questions he doesn't want to
answer about a player who doesn't want
to play for him in atlanta here's arthur
smith from yesterday talking about julio
jones
look we encourage our players to they
should speak for themselves and so i'm
not going to comment it doesn't change
anything for us i mean we understand
what our plan is moving forward and we
have like i said we have multiple
private conversations with our players
and those are conversations are going to
remain private on my end
as pete said last night go waste 16
minutes of your life that you'll never
get back watch the entire media
availability as he is constantly
peppered with different versions of that
same question what's up with julio jones
and arthur smith not giving in now maybe
if shannon sharp would call him live on
the air arthur smith would crash that's
maybe the way to get to the bottom of a
thing it's amazing that's still a thing
and and like anything else in our
society
automatically i mean we're gonna have
two sides to everything why does it have
to be two sides to everything why can't
we ever agree on something you know what
it's wrong to call a guy up and put him
on the air
and not tell them you're on the air we
got people who's oh he knew he was on
the air that was all a setup oh no i
know people didn't know he was on the
air it was right they're all over the
place all over the place right i know
people think because there's a prior
relationship that
you know it what and they think that
they also the other thing that jumped
out to me people think like the ringing
of the phone was wired into the studio
no these microphones are that good that
if you put the phone up there it sounds
like it's in the studio it's it there
wasn't that no i i mean i'm i mean of
course you know what i heard i stated
that yesterday i was told by somebody
very close to the situation there so
yeah i mean but you're right it's just
the current environment we're in it's
it's two sides to everything the other
thing drives me crazy is people insist
that julio jones knew he was on the air
because the call came at the time
when
shannon sharp is on the air right every
weekday like like julio jones has memory
exactly when right shannon sharps on the
air and even if he's on the air
he could be in a break right
it doesn't mean he's live on the air
when he calls you and i have people that
that i know fairly well who apparently
don't know my schedule well enough who
will text or call me right it's 79
eastern
friday yeah i mean people don't think of
that yeah all they think of is i'm
calling this person i'm reaching out to
this person or this person's calling me
like i i bet if i started going through
my contact list and calling people up on
the show
there would be a small percentage of
them that would say aren't you on the
air right now yeah i'd be like what's up
right what's up what's going on what do
you need that's what it would be why'd
you call me i don't want to talk to you
click that's what it would be not aren't
you on the air
like why don't you just go do something
other than call me that would be the
more likely response yeah i mean i i
agree with you you're right not
everybody knows like your exact schedule
and is all over that stuff listen at
facebook
at face value who can we test it out
with oh well
i know i'd love to tell you to call like
my dad right now or something like that
call big bill
hey get your butt up are you awake oh
okay good are you watching okay good if
you're not wake the hell up and let's go
uh but no i i mean again yes i i don't
believe that julio jones had any idea
there yeah there's a prior relationship
with shannon sharp i don't know
he answered the phone it went on it
wasn't cool if that's how it went down
like we said yesterday but i mean hey at
the end of the day i don't think it
really did any big time damage like i
was talking about yesterday a little
like yes
now the cat's out of the bag we know he
wants to be traded
but i think ultimately as long as
there's more than one team interested
everybody knows he's been wanting to be
traded here for a long time and all of
that that
something will get done here at some
point but the one thing i advise the
falcons is you know you just don't give
this guy up for free that's for sure i
still think he's got some good mileage
left on those legs and he's still too
talented to just sell him down the river
for a third round pick or something like
that
i spent some time yesterday actually
taking a break from
copy paste snarky comment yeah and
fishing around
to find out right who's out there right
who's lurking and more importantly more
importantly
was there a window that the falcons blew
yeah during draft week and
look i don't know
what teams now we've seen
statements
social media messages etc from players
we'll talk about that in a second but
that doesn't matter unless they're also
the gm or the owner of the coach of the
team
no teams have moved yet we're a week
away from the day when the falcons can
do this trade officially and realize the
cap savings that kick in after june 1.
you still can have the deal tentatively
done today tomorrow friday memorial day
weekend whenever up until next wednesday
but that's when the window opens on
officially doing the deal and getting
the savings right
my understanding is and remember it was
the monday before the draft all of a
sudden three different reporters all
have the same thing on julio jones not a
coincidence not an accident not a
mistake it's the falcons getting the
word out so that teams know before they
put in a card round one round two
specifically
that
in lieu of that you can do a deal for
julio jones now it wouldn't have been
2021 draft picks because the deal
couldn't be official until next
wednesday but still you know you're
getting the guy as of june 2.
and my understanding is
they could have had a second round pick
i got to be careful here they could have
had a second round pick
and completely and totally unloaded the
15.3 million dollar salary for julio
jones before the draft but they wanted a
one yeah they wanted a one right and
they didn't say let's just take the two
and let's let's get rid of the 15-3 and
be done with it and the muhammad sunu
thing chris i don't feel impediment i
bet because they got a second round pick
for muhammad sunu and there's a certain
gentleman
who has been extremely successful in
business his entire life can't process
the idea that they got a second round
pick from muhammad sunu and they can't
get more than that for the guy who has
been one of the most important players
in the franchise over the last decade
and that's owner arthur blank he wants
at least a two and before the draft they
were holding out for a one and i think
if you would start attaching folks to
lie detector test now in atlanta they'd
say damn we should have taken the two
and gotten rid of the 15.3 million
salary when we had the chance yeah well
i mean that that's the risk you take now
yeah when you sit here and wait and see
what happens i mean yeah sometimes you
just got to take the best deal available
at that moment if you're not really sure
exactly
you know what will happen in the future
you know again
it's too many people me me included you
get caught up in like oh apples to
apples and just comparing things oh he
got a second run for that guy should you
get better for that oh there was a lot
of circumstances around muhammad and
sunu you know attracting a second round
pick in that trade right mike i mean we
had there was a number of teams who were
kind of in a super bowl window who were
desperate to find one more receiver and
that drove up the price from muhammad
sunu i mean i think from everything we
know what was it it was i mean we i
think we heard it was you know the 49ers
the patriots a few other teams involved
in that all it takes is two all it takes
is all the jacks up the price exactly
49ers and patriots that's right and
there you go you get a second round pick
so
but i i will say this you know i don't
know how arthur blank feels now whether
he'd be willing to give this call
yeah right call him up let's see if he's
uh paying attention wake up arthur but
i i don't know i would think at this
point and as long as atlanta as you
stated is allowed to or does
pay a certain amount of his salary
that
i think second round pick is still very
real option and honestly i think if you
get the right teams involved here i
wouldn't be shocked if maybe it's a real
good team that felt like hey our first
round pick's gonna be at the end of the
first round this year
and we're willing to do that you know i
would not be shocked i i don't like you
know like i said mike i just think yes
there's risk here but if you feel like
you know the risk is
not too great and you have enough info
that the health is comfortable to you
where he's at julio jones you know the
talent on the field is still it's still
damn special when he's out there there's
no denying that
but here's the reality yeah because this
deal wasn't done before the draft i'm
looking at the 2021 picks right now
right you've got teams that took
receivers that are now not going to be
interested in julio jones if they even
were but i think we can at least say
anyone that used a first round pick on a
receiver or a second round pick on a
receiver would have at least stopped and
said hmm let's see now we may have to do
some work from a cap standpoint to
absorb a 15.3 million salary but hey
this guy is a proven commodity proven
commodity versus roll of the dice when
we know even though no one says it in
advance of the draft because god forbid
we undermine the hope that everyone
sells to every fan base before the draft
that they're all drafting future hall of
famers
we've seen the rams consistently take
the known commodity not that the rams
could have found a way to spend 15.3
million dollars under their cap but
could you imagine the rams with julio
jones that's a rams move isn't that a
rams move and they took two two out well
with the second round pick that's a rams
move now i don't know what picks they
have in 2022 it's easier to i think
identify the picks they they don't have
the the list is longer of the picks they
don't have than the picks they do have
but you know i there were teams there
were teams and then after the first two
rounds of the draft those teams would
say well why would we give up a second
round pick for next year when we used a
second round pick or a first round pick
on a receiver this year so it's it's a
it's a tougher universe that's why they
did it
three days before the draft began of
course that's why that report landed the
monday of draft week it is but they
didn't pull the trigger well ball was on
the tee and they said we'll wait for a
bigger ball we'll try to kill two stones
with one bird well yeah i mean you're
right yeah well i think you know i think
the other the other side of that is nfl
teams look at it and go into it even
though
yeah a lot of the teams might have
needed receivers we knew there was
a lot of really good receivers to be had
in the first three or four rounds of
this nfl draft to where teams look at it
then two three days before the draft
where they go
we'll get we'll get somebody we'll we'll
figure it out somebody will i'll be
there you know with the right grade that
matches where we're picking and that'll
happen
and
you know what happens is there's a
handful of teams that that it didn't
happen to or maybe they didn't get to
fill that need specifically you know
maybe there's a team that was there in
the end of the second round and they go
oh man we wanted a receiver but all the
guys that we really had valued at this
level are not there and we're not going
to waste you know the end of the second
round pick uh on on the next guy we have
as an end of the third round pick type
grade so again i still think there could
be a market you know i think you and i
we've discussed a few teams out there to
where
i think you could really look at it and
go
there's there's a real need they could
really use him to help their football
team out you know and and i know i know
yesterday i talked about i had heard
from people in the know there down in
atlanta that the titans the patriots
were on his radar uh julio jones as far
as teams he'd want to play for and why
wouldn't they want him i mean
i mean why not i mean that makes sense
for both of those football teams you get
into the colts you know that's another
one i think we could sit here and go
makes a lot of sense they're really got
just about everything you need except
for maybe
one extra difference maker on the
offensive side of the ball and then of
course there's green bay so right there
there's four teams right there we've
mentioned who all have high hopes for
2021 all have a real need and we'll see
if that drives up the price and maybe
gets atlanta closer to what they want in
this trade deal
green bay isn't going to do it though no
i don't think they should i know they're
not going to do it no it's the ultimate
tool to placate aaron rodgers and
they're not going to do it we're going
to have a draft coming up in hour two of
the destinations
for julio jones also a player from one
of the teams that likely will make it on
to the draft he's been lobbying for
jones to come to town again though he's
not the gm the owner of the coach so it
doesn't really matter one last point
though chris yeah we pivot to our daily
aaron rodgers update
i i still think there's a scenario
where the falcons have to keep him and
even though he said i'm out of there
right the only way they get their best
possible trade package is yeah let him
show up right prove he's healthy right
come out and make an impact and then
as teams understand here's where we are
yes here's where we could be how do we
get there on the fly oh julio jones oh
second round pick oh exactly the rest of
his salary for this year now and this is
where
him going on the air without knowing he
was on the air this is where it hurts
the falcons it hurts the falcons because
when it's time to negotiate with chris
baldwin the colts gm right if if the
cults are interested
and the falcons start saying hey you
know what that offer's not good enough
we're just going to keep him chris
powell is going to say sure you are
sure you are okay fine keep him i mean
there's before julio jones does the i'm
out of there thing
it's a much more plausible scenario
where he stays and he's there and
there's a possibility he's traded during
the season that's much harder to sell
now which means it's going to be harder
to squeeze if you ultimately only have
one team yes one team right if you
ultimately have one team it's going to
be harder to squeeze what you want out
of that team and at some point you got
to ask yourself
how badly do we want to save face yeah
how badly do we want to create 15.3
million in cap space how badly do we
want to get whatever we can in the draft
next year for this guy
and there is that ego that's cooked into
it as someone said to me yesterday
they're not taking less than a two
because arthur blank would be
humiliated yeah to get less for julio
jones than he got for hamas well you
know what sometimes you just gotta you
gotta take your medicine and move on i i
you're right you're going to have to
balance that it's it's it's a it's a
balancing act i mean with that i mean
there's yeah it's a tough one it is but
i understand arthur blank's stance there
i mean they they will and i i believe
this is something i said from the start
they will get eviscerated by the no no
the know nothings on twitter and social
media
and when you know they see the post that
julio jones just traded for
a second round or a third round pick and
they're all gonna go what they traded
well how stupid is the falcons
organization i know there's a point
where you have to say screw those people
i don't understand i understand twitter
is
twitter is a cesspool the the town
square
with a million people in it and they can
pass around a micro a megaphone
microphone megaphone
you can they can pass around something
through which they can talk and and
someone can hear it i know it doesn't
mean you have to care about it i know a
person's voice that gets amplified so
what if it's somebody if it's a fan who
doesn't know what the hell is going on
if it's somebody in the media who
doesn't understand the nuance of of
shedding 15.3 million in cap space and
maybe you have to take a fourth round
pick to shed the 15.3 million in cap
space i mean there's a point where you
have to say we don't care about the
reaction we got to do what's right for
us no you're you're right mike there's
no doubt i'm just making a point that
you and i both know you're right owners
of these people they do you know succumb
to the pressure of that type of stuff at
times that's all i was trying to make
the point but you're right you gotta you
gotta block it out you gotta do what's
best for the football team and i mean i
kind of i i agree with you
you know the fact that yeah you could
keep them and and that that's probably
going to be your best chance to maximize
like you said show you know look at what
he's doing he's healthy he's doing great
oh you're a super bowl contender you
need a wide receiver well
uh he's doing great for us we'd like a
first round pick you know that that i
think is the way they probably maximize
unless they can get some multiple
desperate teams right now at this moment
bidding against each other the other
aspect i'll just throw out though about
that scenario that would scare me a
little bit
the the scenario that you talked about
you know keeping him showing everybody
he's healthy and then maximizing that
way only thing i'd be scared there a
little with if i'm atlanta is going like
what if we got out to a hot start and
the offense is rolling under arthur
smith and julio's playing great and
calvin everybody's doing good and all of
a sudden we're four and one
you might be like you might really get
you know a lot of backlash if now you're
trying to trade julio jones everybody's
gonna be like wait we're good what are
we doing here
that's the only scenario i could see
isn't being a negative there and and
that continues to be an unrealistic
scenario because julio jones said
himself
i'm out of there yeah and
and look this dates back three years out
of the blue
they had a problem with julio jones why
because they're paying matt ryan 30
million a year and julio jones is making
15.
and they had to finesse it the entire
2018 offseason and that's the other side
of this too
once julio jones said what he said then
all of a sudden
you see the reports that julio has to be
traded several months earlier and the
fact that they've been accommodating
they do a good job of keeping the dirty
laundry they do in the building yeah
and and it makes you wonder how much
more dysfunction is lurking behind the
curtain
than we truly know about and i think
there may be more they were able to hide
that there may be more and it may be
he's never going to play for them again
he's just never come out and said it
it's never been leaked and they're just
going to have to do the best deal they
can and move on and it's entirely
possible they've already given him their
word that they will
trade him i remember when they had the
regime changed last year middle of the
season arthur blank said matt ryan is
going to have a voice in whether or not
he stays i don't think he specifically
said julio jones is going to have a
voice but it's entirely possible that
over the course of the last six months
they've said to julio we'll take care of
you you've given us 10 good years you're
ready to move on we're going to do that
and it puts them in a position where
they got to do it whatever the best
offer is they got to take it and they
held out during draft week for something
better that may not be there i don't
know i don't know what's there because
as of right now there's no one who's
stepping up with a clear interest in
getting a trade
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports